hi my name is William Chris Sumter and I
play Spencer Haywood hiya my name is
anara Simone and I play Sandra hi my
name is Aya Furukawa and I play not
Dakota and I play amesh hi I'm Iman
Benson and I play ilanka I'm igb rigney
and I play Kevin and I am Adia and I
play Sheree Ian and we are the cast of
The Midnight Club and we're here with
BuzzFeed to answer your burning
questions
if you haven't finished the season
please don't watch this video come back
to it when you have
there was a day I remember when somebody
came offset and told us to shut up
no or something
or
something
we were all yelling at him because that
was Chris
I was just gonna say spending every day
with these guys
Mike is so generous as you know a
director writer and everything I think
he put a lot of care and time into each
and every one of us it all feels very
like collaborative too yeah
and he's really patient like I love how
patient he is because like is my first
time on a set at all so like I didn't
know anything and it was really cool to
like have him like walk us through
everything and he was like you ask all
the questions you want and it's okay
like I will help you and I'm like okay
great I don't feel like an idiot now
I think like none of the episodes are
predictable that's what's so good about
Mike's writing I mean you think you know
where it's going and then and then you
read an episode and you're like well
it's way off
[Music]
yeah I mean it was really cool everyone
was a lot younger we were I mean we're
all the same age so that was cool it was
very loud on set all the time and it was
very energetic but it was cool just to
come back because like igby was there
and Sam and Zach and it was like coming
back to like school after going into
summer like summer camp or something
yeah and we got to share some of the
same uh crew as well oh yeah that was
great so we knew all the makeup people
and everybody very comfortable
environment yes
well I've been a big fan of his for so
long I started watching him with uh
iZombie oh my gosh and just getting to
meet him is just so great my character
in my episode is like awestruck to like
meet that character and it was you know
it was easy to play that because I
myself was like I'll get to like play
with Raul and he's like all right mate
and I'm like
I'm rahul's mate
damn's amazing I mean she really brought
Julia's character to life and can I say
is it Julia no no it's Shasta
I learned so much from her as well and
as well as Matt I think Matt was in
Midnight Mass too it's great I mean he's
the best father figure on and offset too
[Music]
me and Chris got to do the black and
white yeah and that was so cool because
we did like everything we tried to do
the Cadence of how those noir films were
as well and we got to rehearse so much
together so it was really really fun
yeah for that episode anara was just
like painted like gray well she was
bleeding out on the floor giving a
killer monologue and surprisingly I
didn't notice at all I was like wow I'm
in it right yes your tears were just
yeah
that could be a ballerina which is not a
sentence that I ever thought I'd say no
natural Grace at all so that does show
the pair of movie Magic yeah I totally
feel the same about the movie Magic
thing because my episode in episode 8
was all just me driving
I don't know how to drive I've never
driven a car in my life and I actually
have a fear of driving so you know
during the entire shoot I was nervously
kind of activated my thing going if I
hope I don't look like I'm just
[Music]
the set pieces and the costumes and the
hair and makeup that we got to play with
was really fun for me too I just for my
episode episode five they blocked off
the entire Street and they made like a
video game store with like vintage video
game pieces and like it was just so
crazy to see because I never see that in
actual real life today they're not
vintage I had a second and I could drive
when I was a kid
oh my gosh
I would say that everybody should pay
attention to what's in the basement and
I will leave it at that oh that's a good
one it was Pitch Black actually like we
had the real like flashlights to
actually see what we were doing yeah so
it was just a scary yeah
there's one scene in particular
ly it's written that rats kind of run
across in front of me and I thought they
were gonna CGI it and I get to set that
day they have like cages of like rats
plus the dark basement and then rats
running across your feet it's pretty
Eerie down there
foreign
[Music]
yeah we were kind of learning as we went
along because we were getting episodes
as we were shooting like we were getting
scripts as we were shooting so we never
really fully knew like where we were
going along our journey which was kind
of cool because then we had to really be
in the moment and just like live in our
characters right then and there and then
we would find out what would happen in
the next block we did get those little
timelines though oh yeah yeah so we all
kind of had a rough idea of um where our
characters were gonna go we knew that
the pit stops we were going to make
along the way but we know all the little
interlude moments those were just
surprises yeah they did yeah
yeah a whole breakdown of like our past
as well which was really helpful so yeah
we knew exactly where we were at that
time at least
[Music]
I mean I I definitely want uh I I want
Dr Stanton to come tell a story for the
Midnight Club that's my it's my biggest
hope if we get a season two
[Music]
Heather there's an icon
she's so fun and humble like the
sweetest human being ever yes she's also
just like very I don't give up you know
what I mean like she's pretty badass I
remember one time she took me to go get
fried chicken and she pulled up outside
of my house to like drop me off and she
held up traffic for like 15 minutes
while she told me a story everyone was
like ah uh she was like blowing kisses
together
I was like okay I'm riding with you
Heather's sick
[Music]
we did the first table read in the
library which was so cool because then
we because we had actually we never saw
it the whole set and it was done at that
time yeah that was really really cool
yeah the moment of just walking into
this massive library is honestly one of
the most magical moments being there
yeah
[Music]
yeah well they found me on Tick Tock in
the dark corners of the internet
I talked like casting or taking the piss
when they asked me to audition because I
was like
but I've never acted so it's like you
know so I submitted like a sales tape
and I was like I'm never gonna hear back
from them and then they they rang me and
told me I got it and I was like
sure
it's like sure so yeah you just kind of
I mean we were all a lot of us are in
the same boat so we're just kind of like
threw ourselves into it and you know we
had each other so it wasn't I'm not
gonna lie though some days like did go
back to my trailer and I was like
yeah I thought it was a scam because it
was so good to be true you know I was
like I was like Jesus like I'm gonna be
on Netflix and because I got a call the
very next day I sent in a tape because
they were looking for a mesh like I
think I was the last person to get past
and uh yeah it was it was if they're
like oh we love you we want to get on
Zoom and I was like okay here we go
take all my money
[Music]
for me it was the whole scene at the
very end spoiler I can say that though
because that was just a lot of crying
all day and then like you guys were just
it was like and like driving in the car
I actually like drove away in the car it
was very tough but that scene I was
really really proud of and it was nice
to have like literally everybody in the
scene with me obviously the moments
between amesh and natsuki I think those
private moments where we really express
ourselves to each other and stuff
um those scenes were really really
special yeah I'd say because amesh you
get to see a whole different side of him
and I just I love playing a very you
know malleable character and I feel like
once you get to see a mesh this like
vulnerable side that's very that's very
fun to see for me I want to say um for
episode nine I had to I was like
shrapped to a scientific machine that
was supposed to be lasering in my eye it
was like a screw that I like started
picking at while I was like screaming
and I remember at some point it like
fell and I like slit I sliced my finger
and I was like bleeding and I was like
and and I don't think they noticed
because they were like keep rolling keep
rolling perfect keep screaming oh my God
and I'm like actually bleeding out on
the floor and I remember like that day
being like wow I'm losing oxygen but
then I saw the result not like that was
amazing thank you guys for Rolling that
was insane yeah it's such a delicious
it really is I love the moments that I
got to I think in ilanka's story I have
a couple moments with Ruth uh it's your
character Scotty oh yeah together oh
with the umbilical cords yeah yeah and I
think those moments are really beautiful
I like just remembering Anya like we
told stories about her in episode 10
this is a spoiler
I just loved like how we were all
telling our story about Anya and
remembering her and
um it was such a beautiful day too
because like everybody was crying we cry
a lot on this show we cry a lot but um
it was just really beautiful to like
just remember her and commemorate her
and stuff so I loved it I'm gonna go
super early in the season I was so
nervous about Kevin meeting alanka that
was like I was very nervous about that
scene but I think it came out pretty
well yeah there was a a scene in episode
two with Lanka where Anya has another
goiter
um and gives a tour for kind of saying
like pity isn't isn't helpful and it was
a huge big
monologue I'm not very good at putting
things like into words like how I'm
feeling and I remember like how I felt
as a disabled teenager I'm like that's
how I felt I was just never able to put
it into words that scene for me I could
like feel it when I was saying the lines
like in the pit of my stomach
I wasn't in the room and I felt that
I was I was just peeking through the
door I was like okay
okay
oh my gosh I think before our big kiss
scene we were like all right we're gonna
kiss here we go yeah it was just us in
the green room and we're like we were
doing a circle yeah we were doing walks
around it all right kiss and we would we
would have high five everything we
passed each other and then they're like
all right you're ready all right let's
let's do it yeah we're like okay let's
go
Ayah likes to scare people oh my God I
do thanks BuzzFeed make sure you catch
us in the Midnight Club on Netflix
[Music]